salut la team mantallot récemment je
vous ai fait la deuxième vidéo sur le
mensonge et vous avez été nombreux très
nombreux quasiment tout le monde à me
demander une troisième vidéo alors la
voici je sais très bien que nous sommes
lundi qu'en temps normal c'est jour de
blogues mais au bénéfice de votre
demande je remplace le blog par celle ci
dans la détection des mensonges et donc
des menteurs nous allons nous attarder
aujourd'hui sur le physique et surtout
sur la gestuelle si on s'attarde
uniquement sur les mots alors le risque
de broc augmente le risque de broc
hausse et un terme une espèce de phrase
qu'a inventé paul ekman sur une
discussion qu'il avait eu avec un homme
qui s'appelle broco et tout ce qu'on
subit des travaux dès que man comme moi
qu'on dit le le risque de broc au c'est
qu'on parle du risque d'un jugement
erroné ne prendre quelqu'un pour un
menteur par exemple alors qu'il est
juste simplement stressé abordons le
sujet très intéressant des lapsus
emblématique avant de parler du lapsus
emblématique qu'est ce qu'une emblème
les emblèmes sont des gestes précis dont
le sens est connu de tout le monde toute
la population quasiment peu importe
l'âge il en existe bien sûr des culturel
qui non sens que dans un pays par
exemple en inde souvent on te dit oui
comme ça avec un petit hochement de tête
en europe on a une soixantaine de gestes
qui ne nécessite ni money contexte pour
comprendre le sens de ce qu'ils veulent
dire par exemple si je vous fais oui/non
bien par là toi ou encore le haussement
d'épaulé et veut dire quelle importance
le doigt d'honneur vous le savez très
bien ce que ça veut dire
la main au niveau de l'oreille le pouce
pour faire du stop habituellement sans
paroles les gestes ont aucun sens si je
vous fais juste des gestes comme ça vous
ne comprendrez pas ce que je vais vous
dire c'est normal alors que les emblèmes
on sait exactement qu'est ce qu'elle
veut dire et là où ça devient
intéressant c'est que les emblèmes
peuvent être réalisées inconsciemment ça
donne un lapsus emblématique de la même
manière qu'on peut avoir un lapsus
verbale dans les mots lapsus
emblématique c'est également l'emblème
fuite et c'est à dire c'est pas
l'emblème réalisée à 100% mais en partie
et pas forcément à l'endroit où devrait
avoir lieu en général les emblèmes sont
faites dans ce niveau là pour que
l'interlocuteur ne puisse pas la rater
une emblème chuter va se déporter un
endroit où ils n'auraient pas lieu
d'être
et surtout elle ne va pas forcément être
complète principalement parce que les
emblèmes fuite et sont réalisés
inconsciemment
si je prends l'emblème la plus
percutante par exemple le doigt
d'honneur ça peut être simplement
quelqu'un qui est positionné comme ça
c'est un bout de doigt d'honneur
même s'il est pas fait complètement de
même s'il n'est pas assez bonne place il
est quand même ici tout le monde ne
réalise pas forcément d'emblème futé ou
de lapsus emblématique c'est à peu près
20% de la population là aussi je me base
sur les chiffres des knacks donc vous ne
détecterez pas de lapsus emblématique
chez tout le monde
par contre quand vous en détecter un il
est 100% fiable
quelqu'un qui fait non avec la tête
alors qu'il est en train de vous dire
oui ou linverse une personne qui vous
dit qu'elle était très impliqué dans ce
qui venait de se passer alors que vous
détectez un haussement d'épaulés le soin
des pôles n'est pas un geste naturel
c'est vraiment une emblème jamais
spontanément on va faire ça quelqu'un
qui vous dit qu'il est très calme qui
vit bien la situation qui a et qui a
aucune colère en lui alors que vous
voyez l'emblème du doigt d'honneur
quelque part soyez très attentifs car
comme je viens de vous le dire c'est pas
systématique par contre c'est 100%
fiable ce qui nous amène sur les
illustrant ce qui est différent des
lapsus emblématique les illustrant c'est
ce que je fais à longueur de temps dans
les vidéos c'est de vous parler un petit
peu avec les mains quand on discute avec
quelqu'un on symbolise par des gestes
sans les mots ces gestes n'ont aucune
signification si vous me faites voir une
vidéo de quelqu'un qui remue les mains
je ne sais pas du tout si c'est un
menteur ou pas je sais même pas de quoi
ils parlent
les illustrant sont pas quelque chose
d'inné on n'est pas avec une manière de
faire est de parler c'est un acquis
c'est à dire que ça se contrôle ça se
maîtrise on peut déterminer si on fait
beaucoup de mouvement ou pas selon les
rites sociaux c'est plus ou moins bien
vu on va donc on va un petit peu jauger
notre manière de pardies est d'abord
important c'est de déterminer le rythme
dit lustres en habituel de la personne
est-ce qu'elle parle beaucoup en
bougeant pas du tout essayé de
déterminer sa et vous allez pouvoir
ressentir quand la personne ment puisque
le changement dit lustres on va changer
et quand je dis qu'il va changer c'est
qu'il va diminuer la personne va
beaucoup moins illustré pour deux
raisons principalement parce qu'elle
n'est pas impliquée émotionnellement
dans ce qu'elle dit donc elle ne ressent
pas les choses elle a pas besoin
d'appuyer les choses et deuxièmement
parce que la personne ne fait attention
à ce qu'elle dit elle est trop concentré
sur son discours et elle ne s'est pas
encore forcément tout ce qu'elle va dire
dans son mensonge
donc elle peut pas encore l'illustré
récapitulatif pour les illustrant gérer
le curseur de la personne essayer de
voir comment elles illustrent en temps
normal et ensuite si vous voyez une
nette diminution avec d'autres signes
c'est calme on est enfin parlons
rapidement des manipulatoire parce que
je crois que cette vidéo commence à être
très longue
les manipulatoire c'est quand une partie
de notre corps a touché notre partie de
notre corps voire même un objet à
l'accessoire quand je dis toucher ça
peut être frotté ça peut être gratter ça
peut être simplement toucher ça peut
être oui tiens passé comme ça s'appelle
gratter aussi les zones les plus
privilégiés sont les cheveux les
oreilles
et un petit peu la barbe pour les hommes
un accessoire comme un briquet un
téléphone un crayon qui traînent sur la
table alors que nous disent les
manipulatoire sur le mensonge
on a souvent cru qu'une personne qui se
touchent et en parlant comme ça c'était
quelqu'un qui mentaient systématiquement
c'est pas vrai c'est complètement faux
faux pas complètement pas complètement
mais ça augmente énormément le risque de
broc haut c'est à dire le risque de se
tromper pourquoi parce que les
manipulatoire ressortent énormément dans
des situations qui sont très opposées
dans une situation de stress de malaise
est dans une situation de bien-être et
de détente donc toucher mal à l'aise
plus je vais avoir deux gestes
manipulatoire et plus je vais être
détendu plus avoir de chasse
manipulatoire je vous conseille vivement
de ne pas vous fier qu'à ces gestes là
ils doivent être accompagnés d'au moins
deux trois autres validation pour être
sûr que la personne qui est en face de
vous êtes en train de mentir vous me
l'aviez demandé vous l'avez eue c'était
donc la troisième vidéo sur le mensonge
peut être j'en ferai une quatrième voire
une cinquième dans l'année mais pas
avant je dirais octobre puisque l'aca
ont fait déjà 3 ou septembre si vous me
demandez si vous avez une anecdote
marrante à raconter sur quelqu'un qui a
menti et que vous avez grillé je serais
très très heureux de lire ça dans les
commentaires ça peut être drôle si vous
avez un jour cramer un menteur et que ça
a été assez drôle pour être racontée
vous nous mettez dans les commentaires
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
me le faire savoir en laissant un
sincère et honnête pouce en l'air et
n'oubliez pas de faire tourner cette
vidéo de vous abonner à la chaîne avant
de partir puisque le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao